Well put on your niter application where
there wasn't as a practicing addict in
this area there wasn't there wasn't
violence there wasn't a crime nor
that the prostitution. There wasn't.
All those hallmarks of addiction
that my my friends in the city went through
was a lot gentler like in many ways
like we still you know had to go. We
were still a lot more physically active.
I mean we still climbed up and down the
mountains and hills and cars of water and.
We still find eat a lot more.
Yeah addiction was a lot kinder to me
out here than it would have been in the
cities sure i come
legally without a doubt.
Question. My brain is all right.
I guess.
As sunnyside you know life is a lot kind
of threat exam the country all the country
addicts that i know
and my own experiences lies in with this
as well we just didn't have to do it for
all city addicts. To do
and then i never had to prostitute myself
here i didn't have to steal from people
other than just you know charging tourists
exorbitant amounts of money for dies you
know i didn't have to you know
sell my soul to be an addict here
and you know like i would if i couldn't
get it together to cook a meal i could
always go to the rainbow and
have a meal there i mean i think
that kept me alive it kept me out
of trouble for a really long time.
You know the only time i
ever did go to a city and.
You know i was a practicing addict
i'm. When it was just terrific.
I had a really hard time for about three
or four months until i could get it
together to come home again and.
I think i mean for me like.
I wasn't particularly upfront about
my diction of course everybody knew.
But i didn't go around
discussing it with people
and i guess i didn't pick up heroin and.
I had about three years off i think
when i first came to the country and
when it wasn't here for a while and.
You know i sort of did things in town.
I was part of the community
and so people gave me a lot of leeway for
a long time after i sort of became a
practicing heroin addict again. I
think people still loved me and.
You know i could get away with things
just this you know junkie in town and
and i mean that's a lot to do with the
progression of my disease to you know like
you start off as this sort of gay.
Thing and it takes a long time for the
disease of addiction to wear you down
and you know by the time i was 30 to.
I was a pretty you know i was
a pretty worn out junkie
and i want a lot of my friendships and a
lot of my family by that time and i guess.
The only thing i had going for me
was that i was a country junkie and
that i could survive a lot
more easily here in terms of.
I guess must my physical self and my
psyche than i could a city junkie
or about this person as well.
I was i was one of those
sort of junkies that.
Kept a lot of fronts up so i was my
son was always very well-dressed and.
You know there was always money
for shoes and food and so on
and i kept it from him
that i was a junk you know really protected
him whereas a lot of people don't do
that so much. I certainly didn't
and i mean my mothering front was great
because i could say to myself i'm not.
Too bad a junkie because.
Look my kids this that
and the other and so
that was another part of my own denial about
the process of my diction basically in
that.
You know he grew up around smoking dope
that everybody's kids did you know like the
cops came to our house one day to bust
us and max sat on.
A bad diet like a pillow and that
was his you know big claim to fame
that you know the cops
came and i said on the day
but they didn't find it does day to day
and i mean most people's kids are
probably in that position in
that we all had to tell our children that.
You know what we smoke is illegal
and so if anybody ever asks you
about it at school or whatever.
No we do not do that thing and and
that was just reality so it was always
brought up within the framework of that.
Illegality i suppose.
And let's say like narcotics
was uncool in the early days
but so was alcohol so i mean we never went
and sat in pubs or anything like that.
Like if you were a good hippy.
You just didn't going to pubs and i
didn't going to pubs for about 10
or 12 years it wasn't until
you know the mid 80s
that i even ventured into the nimbin
pub and that was a just so weird.
That i started drinking.
And also the kids have been brought up
and within the framework of an
extended family situation here.
I mean that's one of
the things. No i mean.
In country areas you have that
but in communities all societies like
like we live in here i mean that that.
That's even more fundamental.
I mean the kids get together and
they hang around in in groups
and we look after them.
And i mean you know the community really
good you know the kids an audience
and all the kids and all the
kids want to get together
and you're looking after these groups
and so i'm basically in that situation.
I mean.
People carry i mean people you know if
people are having hard times whether it's
through. Relationships
economics indiction whatever.
I mean people get in there and see
what's happening and help each other out
and so i think they fought with the kids
suffered a lot less than they would in a
very housing commission flat
in the city or something like
that as well i mean that's the thing
about country addiction too i mean it is
different to the city addiction
or the city process of addiction i mean i
magine there are people with with kids
and so on who are city addicts but.
I mean it's it's a very different scenario
of here like we we all have lived here
for years and we all had kids our
kids went to school together
and looked after each other and and we
looked after each other's kids as well.
And so on.
So you know it was it was a really different
trips to an isolated safe you're you
know living in a flat and
st kilda or somewhere
and you don't know other mothers
like we all knew everybody like we'd
and we'd go to the school you know
like we would put on dark glasses
and go to the school fete because we
were still part of the community.
You know it's interesting
that there were about.
That here in the community we go.
You know your views on this
issue. About four years.
I think it's very very hard in
that. In people kind of race why.
I think it's very hard in terms of community
notions of addiction because people
kind of rifai addicts and see
them as the monstrous other
and they see them as somebody to
be really feared and people forget
that everybody has an addict or
an alcoholic in their families
and i put the two into the same category.
I had an uncle who was an alcoholic somebody
else has a sister who was an alcoholic.
Somebody has a husband who's.
Drug addict you know
and it's really important to not
let humans humanness flow away
flow out the drain and i think
that when people talk about.
The addicts and the drug problem.
They just forget it's the person
who lives in the house next door
and it's really really important to have
that sort of notion of of compassion
and humanness with with talking about the
problem because otherwise you can't get
any community kind of cohesiveness
happening. If you split the community.
You don't you don't have to in fact search
for the solution you can just shove
shove the people out of the community.
You can show it you know close down
the method own program shut down
and a looks change and then you
have people starting to die
and then you have people
starting to get desperate
and again you have you know possibly a
serious problem happening helps where
but you know probably a serious
problem still happening here.
I mean there are no kind of concrete
solvable solutions happening there's just
the idea i think that.
We have to look at the problem as a
community and and try and sort of.
See the people with problems
as our friends you know
and i mean that's really hard for people
who don't personally know the addicts like
you just walk past people
outside the rainbow say
and see some you know skunky
person it's really hard.
It's really easy to sort
of vilify them then. And.
And things get hyped up to you know people
sit around in groups talking about the
problem. And they'd say you know
something's got to be done about it.
Something's got to be done
about it but i mean that's.
Basically just prompt some kind of
vigilante action rather than any kind of
positive solution.
Or a speck of drug problem.
So well i think i think i think part of the
reason it's visible is because i don't
think women's drug problem is necessarily
worse. Then that a lot of other places.
I think it's probably better than a lot of
i we've got friends who have moved here
from darlinghurst who can't believe the
furore about the drug problem because i
think this is heaven compared to what
they moved out of in darlinghurst.
I think the drug you know.
The problems with addiction.
Everywhere i think one of
the things about nimbin
and one of the healthy
things about an imminent
that it's not it's not kept behind
closed doors and swept under the carpet.
It's basically.
Pretty much up front and it's pretty
pretty discussed on a community level
and it's tried a lot of people try
to address it on this level and
that there's a lot of people within the
community trying to do something positive
about it. And so.
Yeah probably seems a lot worse
than it is and like i said before
that the drug problem in
indonesia is basically just.
A label an over simplified label of for
a lot of other problems i mean for
homelessness for teenage runaways for
alcoholism for poverty through all these
sorts of things. I mean people.
I mean all those problems come under the
label of the drug problem in most people's
minds who are observing it
and. We're small country town.
With one street. It's very visible.
I mean it's it's very visible and.
What is visible is just young people.
Sitting around outside
a rainbow and whether
or not they in fact have a
drug problem is in there
and they may well just the
people who are drinking.
For awhile i mean those people go
through problems drug and alcohol use.
You know between the age
of 18 and twenty two.
There may be kids who are just doing
that really normal thing again.
They're doing it. Visibly. You know they
may just as easily just be you know.
15 year olds who don't want to go to school
just sitting around hanging out trying
to scare people. You know just
looking groovy having fun
and there's also this interest i
think that it's in it's in there.
I think the certain vested interest that
it's in their. To their advantage to.
To clean up the town so that they're their
businesses or properties or whatever
that
that they're trying to sell to sort of
reasonably affluent middle class people with
which you will do in various
people i mean they will sell land
or services or goods to them.
They want the town cleaned up because i
think these people scare them will scare
these people away and and i think
that there's these people whose allusions
like i've heard allusions about the myth
of nimbin have been
shattered by the reality.
They've got a vivid vested interest in
their illusions they want to find somebody
to blame all their dream didn't come true
and i mean all these people got there.
If this interests in beating up this
hype about the drug problem in nimbin
and really like i don't think it's
any worse than anywhere else.
I think it's probably a lot healthier than
other places because because like i said
on a lot of because it is it is upfront
and and it is being talked about
and people are trying to find solutions
and it's i mean i mean what i was thinking
then you know like i think the person
was really offended
when he was asked if he wanted to
find out more king down the street.
And they perceive these people to be sort
of really kind of system drug addicts
and. I think a difference. You
know. Between kids using bits the.
Getting a bit here and the way we all sat
around 20 years ago getting really quite.
Based on smoking dope. I
mean is that acceptable is.
Acceptable to sort of sit in the
main street really style and
and quite comatose on smoking dope
but not on other drugs like i think that's
one of the hardest things about nimbin
is that there's this drug specificity that
it's okay to smoke smoking dope still
and to me that it's held
us back as a community.
It's held us back in terms of what
people are cheap in the community.
I mean this is very much
protestant work ethic
but you know look if you're sitting around
smoking don't you don't do as much you
don't you don't have the most
wonderful guns in the world.
Maybe you don't sort of be
as creative or whatever
but to me a drug is a drug is a drug
and there's just as many problems with
people sitting around smoking dope as there
are you know we drunks.
Beating up on people always you know people
sticking needles and there are these
and i mean there's this
there's this sort of.
Acceptability about drugs that you know
it's it's okay to sit on the street
or to sit somewhere smoking dope and
it's not okay to use the other drugs
and i find
that really senses the bottom line is
always people have got their own barrow to
push and the people
and the people who get vilified of the most
power powerless people in the community.
Basically the young homeless kids.
The the addicts the psych patients who are
being kicked out of their halfway houses
these are the people.
These are people that are always problems
that everywheres got their
blame for some reason
and in people's mind it
makes it all very simple
and easy if we can just blame everything
on these sort of outlandish out of looking
scruffy people.
I'm doing just get rid of them and
then everything will be okay and
and the people sitting around getting drunk
in the pub think oh you know it's all
their problem and if we go out
and beat up a couple of them
and teach them a lesson you know everything
will be okay and. You know it's just.
So why is just so wide off the mark.
Yet this this simplistic
this simplistic sort of.
Vigilante sort of philosophies has pushed
as a wave of solving always problems all
these problems. Funny because i mean in
many ways nimbin was about being marginal.
I mean 20 years ago we were we
were all very marginalised.
You know by a to choose and
ideologies of the time
and you know as i said
before fashions change and.
And i guess we grow older and
and. The marginal become.
You know more offensive
to us in many ways.
You know i still i guess i don't like
picking up hitchhikers because they smell.
You know like i reckon people can
always have a birdbath or whatever but.
You know that that sort of thing
of the marginal do become.
Stems crime yeah and we have become
the status quo and stuff like that.
When i was using drugs.
I used to walk in the rainforest because
i go up there to grow dope and.
Look at you know.
Things like huge strangler vines that
were quite extraordinary and i go.
God i'm so lucky to live here and be
able to look at this sort of thing.
And i could recognise that intellectually
but i only realised after i
got clean from all drugs
that in fact i had no
connection with that reality
and probably the best part about living
here for me in particular living here
totally drug free is to
look at mine violent
and to be part of my own bind
and in some kind of connection
with it on a spiritual level
and i just feel a real numinous.
Joy in that and i don't experience
that in other places as much
as i do here. When i can walk.
In parts of sydney and feel
that too in parts of melbourne i mean it's
not a peculiarly country experience by
any by any stretch. But i do feel.
And here we go into the realms
of the arcane i do feel
that women is is a very special spot.
Not for the people not for for anything
that we've done in the
last 200 years here.
But i do feel it as one of those
places that is very magical.
I mean it's the only word you can
describe it. Some sometimes here.
Your heart lives up in a
really beautiful way.
And i always get homesick for this
area and want and want to come home.
I suppose you know any
place can become home.
But for me this this place has
become a very special spot.
And i guess the people to you
know like the people who stayed
are a lot of fun. You know and people
have come and gone over the years
and i mean they to you
know have their place here
but for the people who came
here and decided to stay
and have just kept on year after year.
I mean we are a community and that
that sense of community is is
very special also because.
Certainly i mean i've lived in other
country towns you can walk down the street
and you can not and say hello to everybody
but i mean we share a continuity
and concern and continuum here that
goes back over a long time and.
And that's a special thing to.
I just think
that the really really strong thing
about the community up here is the fact
that we do really sort of cherish the
diversity of. People i mean here.
The junkies can come. I mean by
homeless kids come. The ferals come.
The psych patients come give me all the
you know i mean here basically all these
people come and. And they're
taken they're taken as they are.
I mean they're not vilified
for that they're there.
If i me if if i get on in the community
they're accepted that there's doors open.
I mean i can get on that
the diversity here is
that humans is pretty much
cherished and i think.
I think that's a fantastic thing i think.
That's the issue that's going on at the
moment i mean the pressures in outside
society i mean. They want to
modularize people like that.
That's the global sort of
pressure homogenise everything.
I mean what you've got
here is. Is incredible.
I mean incredible range just
all sorts and mania x and
and. And just all sorts
of people and we get on.
I mean we do get on and.
And the community as a whole does really
resist this pressure to homogenise in this
this pressure to.
To to vilify marginal people and i think
that's the strength of this community
and that's and that's that's what a
lot of tea. I mean. A lot of the old.
Settlers who have been
here a long time. I mean.
That's where our strength lies in our in
our desire to preserve the diversity not
only of the rainforests but that of
human culture and people and all
that the different subcultures that exist
and i think that's why i mean or go on
and that's why issues like drug addiction
will be sort of kicked about and.
About you know in the open and
that's why that's why when when when
when commercial
and economic pressures come on onto
this community to clean itself up
and to you know rub out the messy bits
and move them on on in the
community will push back because.
I think i think that diversity
is where our strength lies
and i think i think will
maintain you know against.
Against the legal the commercial
you know the cultural pressures
that we're bombarded with and i
think that's the strength community
and one reason i really love here is.